janvier 1622. Il a inspiré des
♪ ♪ ♪
- À la fois roi de la comédie
et génie du drame, Molière
a 400 ans cette année
et il est bien vivant.
BENOÎT BRIÈRE, comédien
- Il ne les fait pas, il neles .
Pantoute, pantoute!
Il est toujours aussi jeune,
aussi impertinent, formidable.
- Sachez que pour céans,
j'en rabats de moitié.
- Jean-Baptiste Poquelin, dit
Molière, est né le 15 janvier
1622 à Paris. Il est l'auteur
d'une trentaine de pièces
de théâtre, des classiques
comme "L'École des femmes",
"Le Misanthrope"...
- L'apprumains.
- ... et "Le Malade imaginaire".
- De toutes les affreuses
demandes.
- Eh bien, moi, j'en ai à faire.
- Au Québec, il a été joué
49 fois au Théâtre du Nouveau
Monde, qui a ouvert ses portes
en 1951, justement avec
la pièce "L'Avare".
LORRAINE PINTAL, directrice art.
Théâtre du Nouveau Monde
- Depuis ce temps-là,
"L'Avare"L'Avare"L'Avare" a été.
Et "L'Avare", dès qu'on parle
de cette pièce, c'est le TNM.
Et Jean Gascon, Jean-Louis Roux,
Olivier Reichenbach, moi-même,
on est tous restés fidèles
à Molière.
- Que pourrez-vous dire, vous,
si je vous fais voir maintenant
que le galant est avec elle?
- Cette fidélité, ici au Québec,
est due au mordant jamais égalé
de Molière. Normand Chouinard
a joué dans cinq pièces
de Molière et il garde un doux
souvenir du "Tartuffe".
NORMAND CHOUINARD
comédien et metteur en scène
- Mais non, madame, pour
être dévôt... je n'en suis
pas moins homme.
Et en 12 pieds...
Molière venait de faire
de Tartuffe un "cruiseur",
comme on dit aujourd'hui.
Mais pour être dévôt, je n'en
suis pas moins homme, c'est...
madame, j'ai envie de vous.
- Se mettre une douceur
utre pareil.
- Ce son friand qu'on donne
à mon oreille.
- Molière avait la plume bien
e. Ses vers et sa prose
ont perduré, même s'il défiait
à l'occasion le roi de France,
Louis XIV.- Lie au vin est myth.
- Et pourquoi veux-tu
que j'y crois?
- Benoit Brière a jouéle rôle de
dans "Dom Juan", qui prononce
les tout derniers mots
de la pièce.
- Et là, il tend
au roi et il demande :
"Astheure, vous l'avez eu, ce
que vous vouliez, mes gages...
mes gages. Astheure, paie.
Tu m'as censuré, jplus
d'argent, je t'ai écrit une
pièce pour te faire plaisir,
clergé, astheure, paie."
Il faut être quand même pas
pirementour écrire
des affaires de même
en pleine face du roi.
- Tout cela... me fera mourir.
- Molière était aussi comédien.
'ailleurs 'ailleurs 'ailleurs 'é
quelques heures après être
monté sur scène pour jouer
son "Malade imaginaire".
Il avait seulement 51 ans.
- Tu n'as pas, oui, parlé
de ce qui s'est passé
dans mon absence.
- J'ai bien, oui, parlé
de quelques petites choses.
- Le 400e anniversaire
du plus grand homme de théâtre
français a été assombri par
la pandémie et la fermeture
des théâtres. Molière aurait
sans aucun doute trouvé
une façon de s'en moquer.
Ici Louis-Philippe Ouimet,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.